the inferno that translation was not a
kind of writing it was so much fun as
well as agony to try to solve an English
equivalent of the Tirtzu Rima and there
was the exhilaration of knowing that
though I might miss some things I had
something going for me that no one had
ever done most of the translations that
I know indeed all of the translations I
know the ones I admired the ones I
thought were not so good we're kind of
slow
Dante moves along the commedia is very
rapid in Italian the church Serena is
like a supercharger let's move from an
episode to a narrative to a conversation
to philosophy to a lyric very quickly
and by translating his sentences rather
than his lines and by using rhymes that
were rhymes for English like rhyming for
war and car not for door and horror and
with feminine rhymes making it hammers
simmering glimmer not hammer and glamour
and slammer varying the vowel I had him
I had the technical means and working on
that translation I possibly was thinking
about Dante's profound insights and the
greatness of the poem in some part of my
mind but consciously and mostly I was
thinking about the equivalent of dove if
you put a hinge here and pull up with a
thread there this part will come up and
they're gonna be a little rubber bumper
there it was there was like building a
ship in a bottle or having a wonderful
new knitting pattern or sewing pattern
or designing a guard where you're
calculating the shade where the wall
will be in the heights of the different
things he was a the best puzzle it was
the best challenge of technique I had
ever encountered plus it was exactly
like writing only I didn't have to think
about what the same thing
translate as I've said before is a
misnomer
you can't translate from Italian to
English or to Japanese or to swedish
translate means translator a needs to
carry a cross you can't carry a meaning
across the word in Italian is the word
an attack and the English word is a
different word Pinette is not great
they're pointing the same to the second
reality but the words are different
they rhyme with different things they
come up different routes the better word
is the old word people use in English I
did an English Inferno and when you
English it you try to be as faithful as
possible to the literal meaning and you
tried to devise an equivalent
the most beautiful translation of the
commedia is by Longfellow Longfellow who
is a great master of sound and who was
by profession a professor of Italian he
had lectured on Dante's so often that
probably in the course of his lectures
and readings he had translated a lot of
the poem without even intending to he
translates it into blank verse it's very
useful as a trot the scholarship is
dealt with some cruxes differently from
the way Longfellow does it's beautiful
you eat any 10 or 12 or 15 20 lines of
it it's gorgeous
it's hard to read a lot of it
particularly for an American reader it's
an all tonic blank verse that he uses so
the word order that enables him to
follow the Italian word order quite well
line for line but it does not flow in an
idiomatic way for a modern American
reader so it's very beautiful it's a
good thing to read to remind yourself of
the beauty of the poem and I admire it
and respect it very much
you